um welcome to the final session of the
meet the fellows event um so we have
three talks in this session by fellows
in the graph limits and processor
networks program and the first talk is
by agree will tell us about local
algorithms to predict networking
thank you um my name is jaganna i'm a
phd student at stanford advised by amin
sabari uh today i'm going to talk about
epidemics on network the first part is
going to be the five minute version of
the longer talk i gave last week then
i'll get to more empirical work
so we have an infection spreading over a
network like covet for example and the
properties of this network matters on
how the infection is going to spread for
example if we have isolated sets of
families if one of them get infected
randomly from travel there is no like
risk for the others but on the other
hand if you have like a particular
family if they get infected there is a
chance of like leading to an outbreak
the main question we are asking is that
what kind of information about the
network do we need to predict an
outbreak
and this question has been traditionally
answered mostly with a modeling
perspective so there are two steps in
the more traditional ways to answer this
question first is to choose a network
model to see how the interaction between
people
goes for example there are many of these
modern erdo trainee configuration models
stochastic block model
etc and you choose one of these model as
you desire then you have to estimate the
relevant model parameters so for example
if you chose erdo training you have to
estimate what's the average degree and
if you chose like configuration model
you have to estimate what's the degree
sequence
and
but the question is that we don't know
what's the right model and can we have a
model-free way of estimation of
epidemics
to answer this question we are
considering a very simple epidemic model
um which we have like a network of in
individuals or the nodes edible
interaction initially one node uniformly
at random is infected
they transmit the disease independently
to their neighbors with fixed
probability p
and
after that they recover and they're
involuntary infection
so one of the infected transmitted
disease the same happened with the new
infected node until everybody tried
their chance this is equivalent to sir
model with constant recovery time and
the main thing we are interested here is
an outbreak the event of an outbreak
where super constant number of nodes are
getting infected
now going back to our question which was
like how we can estimate epidemic
without knowing the model we propose a
simple algorithm for that it's a local
algorithm to predict epidemics
this algorithm has
information about the network we don't
know the network but through this oracle
we are learning something about it
so the algorithm gets k as an input
and it first draws a uniform random no
and i assume that node is the
first infected patient
and
starting from that note it sees if if it
can infect other people in one round of
simulation so here for k equal to four
you see inflates one neighbor that never
infects another one but the infection
dies out so in this run of the scenario
the answer of the algorithm would be
zero like and there was an infection of
size four
and a simple estimator using this
algorithm would we just take average
over a few queries that you get
now the question is how many queries do
i need
and in our work with christian and ami
we showed that if you have a convergent
sequence of
well-connected networks or some sort of
weak expanders
then together one minus epsilon
approximation of the epidemic size and
the epidemic probability
i only need constant queries with k
equal to a constant as an input
the second part of the theorem we showed
that this final size of an infection is
either a constant or a linear size in
terms of the network so there is no in
this same situation
a few notes about the algorithm that
those that program i showed you recovers
many of the previous results on
different network models without
assuming them so for example
configuration by the preferential
attachment and household models
the second thing is that the algorithm
has some nice properties for example it
can be implemented in constant time
it's model free
and
it preserves edge differential privacy
and it's extendable to dynamic models
when a nodes come and go
and it doesn't require
anything like local tree like a
structure that some of the previous
model imposed on the graph
and the main technical thing that we
used was graphene
which we saw a lot of nice
introduction by
christian and jennifer last week
so the second part of the talk i'm going
to focus on the application of studying
of epidemics and networks in real life
and this is their application design
school reopening this is a collaboration
with a
bunch of nice professors at stanford and
we've worked with los angeles school
district since fall 2020 and this
a brief background about the sanchez
school district they are the second
largest school district in the u.s with
700 000 students and they have a large
population of underprivileged students
that they really needed to go to school
because of
education and also getting even free
meal
and
back in 2020 when all the schools were
closed
one of the main challenges they had was
that what's the right policy to
uh implement so that we can safely
and
keep the students back to school
and um
for like answering that question we need
to first identify how we can quantify
risk here and the more traditional way
about risk or is
having looking at the absolute number of
soldiers
meaning that for example in 2021
california guidelines says that if the
case rate of the community are below 25
per 100k
then the school can be open so this is
just absolute number which is very
sensitive to
maybe like a lot of noise that we have
from covet cases some areas have good
testing so
inherently the case that the report is
higher but are they really schools
not safe to over open so instead we are
taking a relative risk
approach we compare
the
risk that is if the students go to
school
with the
case that they don't go to a school and
they get the infection from communities
like going to groceries or like
playgrounds
and to identify that relative risk there
are two important factors
first is the inbound rate which is the
rate that the students are getting
infected from the community the second
is the within school spread which is the
rate that the students would get the
infection by going to school
and we say schools are safer
to be open if students
in school spread is lower than the
inbound from the community
so the inbound rate can be estimated
from community prevalence and taking
care of like how many
uh cases are in different age groups but
the initial spread to estimate that we
are using the network model
and um
here i'm showing you a hypothetical
school network
uh where nones are like either teachers
or students and there are a hierarchy
between like how um
students wouldn't track the higher level
is it whole school then we have grades
and cohorts and we can have different
levels of interaction which are shown
like with different colors here
and
then there is also the community in
boundary that students and teachers are
getting effective from the whole
community and i'm hiding a lot of
details here but like with different
parameter settings that we set
both for the number of edges that we can
have and the
strength of them we can now compare the
community moderate with how the school
how the infection is spreading within
this school
and
here i'm showing you some qualitative
results
and
so here in this table different rows
different blocks of rows shows different
seven day average cases in the community
and we are bindering these different
counter measures that can be implemented
in school from like low medium high for
example how much they're using masking
how much they're social dispensing or
not and we are
looking at three different testing
scenarios so like whether they're
getting
other students are getting tested every
three day
every week or by weekly and as we see uh
here
in three-day testing and seven-day
testing
school in a spread rate is lower than
the community most of the time
and when we get to bi-weekly testing
and
then
they are mostly not safe except when the
community rates are higher and the
intuition is that if the countries are
so high then 14-day testing is keeping
some students safer from like getting
infected from their
classmates
and uh actually at a usd school reopened
in august 2021 with weekly testing and
they had very few outbreaks before
january on request so they didn't have
really much infected workflow
until then and uh with that i thank you
so much i stopped here and i'd be happy
to get questions
thank you for the very interesting talk
um i have two questions first one is on
the uh dynamics where on the first part
it seems like the agents are trying to
the transmission explore the link once
and then don't transmit
so um but if the transmission is not
successful so the second node is not
immune so it seems there could be also a
second chance for the transmission
i was wondering if you can comment you
can adjust it with like how you change p
maybe uh
it's um it's the same you can think of
like their interaction of nodes and be
modeled with like some poisson random
process
and then if the infection rate if the
interaction time is this is fixed then
it will be equivalent to just finding
some p
it's the same as that
so if the poisson process has happened
twice
then it doesn't matter for me it's just
the first time they get transmitted to
the uses
my second very quick question is the
weekly testing is shown it's going to be
better does that relate to how the like
um incubation period for covet which is
roughly two weeks or right yeah that's
that's a very good question so this uh
here i'm we're using the
earlier variants of kobe where like the
incubation period was longer and i'm
pretty sure if you do the same analysis
for omicron this like weekly testing
wouldn't be as good as this
because the incubation period are
shorter and you need like more frequent
tests to like
get rid of the aspects
the next speaker can set up
and thank you again for the interesting
talk just can you tell us how
actually you you create the last table i
mean how did you measure the safety and
you say
it is safety
how the
also how did you find out the cohorts or
or all
of that in the real practice in in the
school thing
that's a great question so about the
cohort size and school specific uh
parameters we talked a lot with teachers
and principals so like
based on if the
school is like for high school
elementary school we changed them so you
know
you asked them
who students are friends in the no no
not that oh you in the interaction so
like about the cohort size and um school
size as we use uh teachers later but
then about the edges then we assume like
we did since a sensitivity analysis
between like different levels of
interaction that they can have
like uh then at the end of the day
in different parameters we like draw
some hierarchical aesthetics and a
stochastic block
and the ages know but uh just about like
physical character characteristic of
this school like how large is the
classroom or like
those
spread is lower than the community
um no
for school i don't think
i don't know of any
mobility data
[Music]
for general public yeah for there are
some mobility network data available i
think safe graph is the main like
company that like sells those data
safe graph uh
yeah they have the data from the from uh
yeah from gps data and that but even in
those data most of the days like uh
above people above 18. it's not for kids
and above 18 i mean their age so 18 18
18.
yeah yeah
and your parents don't die
more refined information
there are ways to answer that question i
and i there are some publications i mean
and
i'm studying some like
either
for like general population like
vaccination
yeah
and then you could use mobile data in
university people operate
privacy
[Music]
is
okay so
a lot of interesting discussion yeah you
have to do it offline uh let's continue
with the